CORONAVIRUS DID COME FROM THAT
LAB.
WE KNOW HOW THAT IS.
LET'S GET INTO IT NOW WITH A
FORMER HOUSE SPEAKER NEWT
GINGRICH NOW A FOX NEWS
POLITICAL ANALYST AND AUTHOR OF
THE BRAND-NEW BOOK BEYOND
BIDEN, REBUILDING THE AMERICA
WE LOVE.
THAT TITLE IS RIGHT ON TIME AND
WE'LL GET TO THAT IN A MOMENT.
YEAH, THIS IS PART OF IT, RIGHT?
IT IS SO GREAT TO HAVE YOU IN
"FOCUS" TODAY.
OUT OF THE BREAKING NEWS YOUR
TOP LINE THOUGHTS WITH WHAT
SENATOR PAUL IS TRYING TO GET
TO THERE.
>> I THINK IN ANY REASONABLE
SOCIETY FAUCI WOULD BE GONE.
HE HAS VIOLATED HIS OWN RULES
AND WROTE A PAPER ON THIS BACK
IN 2012 TALKING ABOUT DANGEROUS
RESEARCH AND WHAT STANDARDS
OUGHT TO BE SET AND ADMITTING
THAT IN THE END THIS WAS MORE
THAN A SCIENTIFIC QUESTION.
THIS DANGEROUS RESEARCH WAS A
THREAT TO THE WHOLE SOCIETY.
I'VE KNOWN FAUCI SINCE HE DID
BRILLIANT WORK ON HIV/AIDS IN
THE 1980s BUT I'M SAD TO SAY HE
IS NOW DESTRUCTIVE, DISHONEST
TRYING TO SAFE HIS REPUTATION
AND DOING SO AT VERY
SUBSTANTIAL RISK TO LIVES
AROUND THE PLANET.
AND IT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE AND
THEY GO THROUGH THIS SAME
CONVERSATION EVERY TIME.
AND FAUCI HIDES BEHIND WORD
GAMES.
THE FACT IS THAT THERE WERE
RUNNING EXPERIMENTS.
THE VERY NOTION THAT HE TRUSTED
THE CHINESE WHEN YOU KNOW THAT
THE CHINESE DICTATORSHIP WAS
LITERALLY LOCKING UP DOCTORS
WHO DIDN'T DO WHAT IT TOLD THEM
TO.
YOU LOOK AT THE ORIGINS OF THIS.
THE EFFORT BY THE CHINESE
DICTATORSHIP TO COVER IT UP FOR
THE FIRST TWO OR THREE MONTHS
AND FOR FAUCI TO SAY I COULD
TRUST THEM BY ITSELF IS AN
INDICTMENT OF NAIVETY.
>> Harris: RAND PAUL IS SAYING
ARE YOU TRYING TO REDEFINE FOR
ALL OF US AND WE'RE ALL
CHILDREN THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
WEBSTER'S OR THE INTERNET THE
DEFINITION OF GAIN OF FUNCTION?
WHICH IS NOT A NEW SCIENCE.
SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO SPEND ALL
THAT TAXPAYER MONEY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT IT IS.
>> YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF THE
QUESTION GIVEN THE DEGREE TO
WHICH CHINA IS STILL CLEARLY A
TOTALITARIAN SOCIETY WHERE THE
DICTATOR XI DEFINES REALL TORE
WHY WOULD THE U.S. TAXPAYERS BE
FUNDING RESEARCH IN A CHINESE
LABORATORY?
THE ANSWER IS SOUTH ASIA AND
SOUTH CHINA IS A MAJOR CENTER
OF THESE KIND OF DISEASES.
WELL, I WOULD MUCH RATHER HAVE
THE BATS BROUGHT TO THE U.S. OR
TAIWAN OR JAPAN OR SINGAPORE
BUT THE IDEA WE'LL SEND MONEY
TO WUHAN IN ORDER FOR CHINESE
SCIENTISTS UNDER THE CONTROL OF
THE CHINESE SECRET POLICE, THAT
WE'LL TRUST -- NOT HAVE PEOPLE
THERE.
BY THE WAY, WHEN IT DID BREAK
OUT THEY WOULDN'T LET US COME
IN.
SO THEY WOULDN'T EVEN LET US
LOOK AT THE RESEARCH WE WERE
PAYING FOR.
>> Harris: THEY HAD SCIENTISTS
IN THE LAB GETTING SICK AND
DYING.
WE DIDN'T KNOW THAT AT THE TIME
AND FIND THAT OUT UNTIL LATER.
>> FAUCI BEHAVES AS THOUGH ALL
OF THIS IS NOT REALITY.
SO IT'S AS THOUGH THERE IS NOT
A CHINESE DICTATORSHIP AND
SCIENTISTS DIDN'T DIE AND IT IS
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE HE IS
PROBABLY THE MOST PROMINENT
SPOKESPERSON ON THESE KIND OF
DISEASES IN THE WORLD.
AND THE FACT THAT HE IS NOW
COMPLETELY DEFENDING HIS
REPUTATION AT THE COST OF THE
PEOPLE NOT JUST IN THE UNITED
STATES BUT WORLDWIDE IS TRAGIC
AND SOME DAY HISTORIANS WILL
WRITE ABOUT IT.
>> Harris: YOU LAY IT OUT WITH
YOUR EXPERIENCE HAVING KNOWN
HIM AND CHINA.
A FRIEND WOULD NOT HAVE KEPT US
OUT LIKE THAT.
THEY WOULD HAVE PARTNERED WITH
US ON DOING THE RIGHT THING
FROM THE BEGINNING BUT ALMOST
LIKE FAUCI IS ACTING AS THOUGH,
WE KNOW IT'S TRUE, HE DOESN'T
HAVE TO SAME MUCH BECAUSE IT'S
UNKNOWABLE NOW.
WE CAN'T GET IN.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT HAVE
DONE WHATEVER IT IS GOING TO DO
AND IT MIGHT BE IMPOSSIBLE TO
GET ALL OF THOSE ANSWERS IN A
MORE CONTEMPORANEOUS.
>> WHICH WOULD LEAD YOU TO
SHALL MORE CAUTIOUS AND HUMBLE.
I DID A PODCAST WITH HIM IN
FEBRUARY OF 2020 WHEN THIS WAS
JUST STARTING AND IT IS
INTERESTING TO GO BACK AND
LISTEN TO IT NOW BECAUSE IN
FEBRUARY HE WAS PRETTY PASSIVE.
THIS IS PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
BE A PANDEMIC OR A CRISIS.
I THINK --
>> Harris: THAT IS CODE FOR HE
IS WRONG.
>> IT IS NOT ME, IT IS HIS
VOICE.
>> Harris: I WANT TO GET TO
YOUR NEW BOOK BEYOND BIDEN
REBUILDING THE AMERICA WE LOVE.
IT IS ON SALE NOW.
>> I DECIDED NOT TO WRITE AN
ANTI-BIDEN BOOK THAT BIDEN
WOULD BE SUFFICIENTLY ANTI-
HIMSELF, THAT'S NOT AN ISSUE.
WHAT WE WANTED TO DO THIS IS
GOING TO BE A MESS.
WE HAVE REALLY BIG THINGS.
BY THE WAY, THE YOUNGKIN HIS
CAMPAIGN REALLY FITS ALMOST
EXACTLY WHAT BEYOND BIDEN TALKS
ABOUT BECAUSE HE TALKED ABOUT
FIXING THE SCHOOLS, HE TALKED
ABOUT CREATING JOBS, HE TALKED
ABOUT DOING THINGS TO BRING
DOWN CRIME.
SO HE WAS TALKING ABOUT IN THE
REAL WORLD ABOUT REAL CHANGE.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE IF WE DON'T GO
THROUGH PROFOUND MODERNIZATION
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE
COMPETITIVE WITH CHINA AND WE
ARE GOING TO LOSE IN OUR
LIFETIME.
I DON'T THINK BIDEN HAS A CLUE.
I THINK JOE BIDEN IS A NICE,
PLEASANT GUY WHO IS TOTALLY OUT
OF TOUCH WITH REALITY
SURROUNDED BY LEFT WING
STAFFERS WHO LIVE IN A FANTASY
WORLD.
I ALWAYS TELL PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR ATTITUDE
TOWARDS THREATS WHETHER IT'S
TERRORISM OR CHINA, IMAGINE
THAT THEY SAW THE LION KING AND
THOUGHT IT WAS A DOCUMENTARY
AND THEY BELIEVED LIONS AND
ZEBRAS DANCE TOGETHER.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND WE'RE IN
A LIFE AND DEATH STRUGGLE WITH
A CHINESE DICTATE ORSHIP THAT
WANTS TO DOMINATE OUR SOCIETY
WHICH HAS HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF AGENTS IN OUR
SOCIETY WHICH HAS A METHODICAL
STRATEGY OF BOTH STEALING
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY AND
BRIBING OUR SCIENTISTS AND
LYING TO US.
>> Harris: AT THE START OF A
DEADLY PANDEMIC.
I DON'T KNOW WHEN YOU STARTED
TO THINK ABOUT THIS BUT IT HAS
ONLY BEEN 10 MONTHS.
>> RIGHT AFTER THE ELECTION WE
SAT DOWN.
YOU COULD -- THE GREAT TRAGEDY
IS THAT BIG GOVERNMENT
SOCIALISM DOESN'T WORK.
DIDN'T WORK IN VENEZUELA OR
ZIMBABWE.
I WAS -- ONCE YOU KNEW WHO WAS
GOING TO DOMINATE AND IT WAS
CLEAR THAT BIDEN GAVE A VERY
NICE INAUGURAL ADDRESS ABOUT
COMING TOGETHER AND THE SAME
DAY HE SIGNED A SERIES OF
EXECUTIVE ORDERS DISMANTLING
WHAT TRUMP HAD DONE.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE IS DOING
BEHIND THE SPEECH.
I KNEW BY THEN WHAT THEY WERE
GOING TO TRY TO DO WOULD BE A
DISASTER.
>> Harris: NOW WE CAN READ
ABOUT YOUR PERSPECTIVE IN TERMS
OF ACTUALLY.
>> WHAT DO WE DO TO FIX THE
COUNTRY ONCE WE WIN?
>> Harris: COULD YOU START WITH
INFLATION?
WE COULD DO A WHOLE HOUR
TOGETHER AND GLAD YOU WERE HERE.
CONGRATULATIONS ON TH